Batting first producer Tim Howard. Well wait,
I'm just gonna get my level here that, that popped up at Purdue.
It is such a beautiful day. Beautiful.
I think it's gotta be like 75 degrees out or something. Sunny. Um,
this is Patrick perdon.
He's a professor of anesthesia at Harvard Medical School and works at mass
general hospital. Yeah. You want to just tell me where we are? We're,
we're standing right now, uh,
in front of the Bulfinch building and I went up to talk to him because in that
building is a, this is the one with the ether dome. You did go miss.
Inside this building is,
it's got like the story of the day that you could say humanity emerged from the
dark ages. Oh, you laugh now. Just wait.
Okay. Here we go. On the fourth floor,
it's on the fourth floor of this building.
We headed in up three flights of stairs into this room.
What a cool room. Oh my God. Is this like,
how would you describe, I've seen any amphitheater, right?
It's also got this awesome,
don't miss this beautiful domed room with lights streaming down from above.
Like the acoustics in here are crazy. It must have been terrifying though.
If you actually hear somebody screaming, I mean, it's so resonated here.
The screams would have been deafening and and absolutely would have been
terrifying. What is this place? Well,
this was an operating room and back in the 18 hundreds when this room was really
in use,
being in an operation was so painful,
it was often permanently damaging to a patient's emotional state.
This is Julie. I'm Julie Fenster. I write about American history.
She wrote a book called Ether Day,
which goes into a lot of detail about the dark,
dark days of surgery in the early 18 hundreds back then during surgery,
there were no painkillers and patients were awake,
probably more awake than they'd ever been in their whole lives.
Some of the patients who remembered the sound of their limb dropping to the
ground or the saw going through their sinew and bones.
Mm.
The smell of their own body being cut into.
Usually the surgeon would employ six burly men to hold a patient down and
instead of having an operation,
some people committed suicide before they would face going into an operating
room,
which were usually located on the top floor of a hospital in part because the
hospital really didn't do itself.
A lot of good to have the screams heard by passers by.
This is such a cool room. Here we are at the top of the ether dome,
but then everything changes.
October 16th, 1846 it's a Friday morning.
I assume the room is full. The the room is absolutely false.
Students were all lined up to watch crowded in the bleachers because they'd
heard something big was going to go down and right there in the middle of the
room is the most esteemed surgeon in America,
Dr. John Warren, about to do an operation.
He brought in a piece in who needed a tumor taken out of his neck and he was
just about to slice into the guy just about to start the surgery.
When this mustachioed fellow bursts in a dentist,
William TG Morton,
and he basically said to warn something that must have sounded completely nuts.
I can erase that man's pain. He didn't actually use those words.
He actually had an appointment with Warren. But according to Julie,
he did have a bag. He had a bag filled with gas,
a gas called ether. And, um, Dr. Warren,
who had the scalpel raised, he puts it down,
stands aside and says with great sarcasm. Well, sir,
your patient is ready. They second, had he ever tested this,
he claimed to have tried it out on some dental patients and on his dog,
on himself and on his goldfish. Nice.
So Martin gets to work
more than sets up his gear, fills up the inhaler, puts it up to the guy's face.
And actually,
because the valve system had just been constructed and he hadn't tested it,
he actually literally had to manually operate the valves with every inhale and
exhale of, of the patient. So he administers the ether using this inhaler.
After about three or four minutes, uh,
the patient becomes unconscious and just at that moment,
Morton turns to Warren and says,
you are a patient, sir.
Dr. Warren brings a scalpel down to the patient's neck and cuts.
And really for the first time in that room,
you could hear the scalpel. You could hear the breathing.
The silence was far more deafening than all the screams that had ever been heard
in that operating theater. No squirming, no moving,
no bulging eyes, no clenched fists.
It must've felt like a miracle.
This a, the news of the operation went around the world as fast as anything.
News of, you know, war or peace didn't travel faster than this.
By the end of the year,
doctors in Europe are using surgical anesthetics and basically the blink of an
eye, the most painful,
horrible experience possibly imaginable became routine,
even forgettable, but also deeply peculiar. Uh,
as was made clear to us when we talked a while back with one of our regulars,
Carl Zimmer, well, my wife and I, we were watching this movie one night.
It was called birth started with Coke Kidman. You. Did you like it? I hated it.
No, it's one of my favorites. Well, okay,
I'm sitting there and I'm hating the movie. You're hating this movie. Well,
I'm just wondering like why am I reacting so negatively to this movie?
I'm just in such a bad mood. I'm feeling lousy. And I think it's the movie.
And I stand and I say, oh, wait a minute.
My abdomen is an incredible pain. Oh, so it's not the move. It's not the movie.
It's me. Appendix about to burst.
We go to the hospital and um, maybe four in the morning, five in the morning,
they're prepping me for surgery. They, you know,
put an IV in me and then they're like, okay,
now we're going to be putting in the anesthetic, you know,
so just relax and this'll be taking effect.
But he says it didn't seem to be working.
So I start thinking about what they're going to be doing to me. Half an hour,
they're going to like take these knives and they're going to cut me open.
They're going to rip my intestines apart.
They're going to pull off this inflamed appendix.
They're going to sew up the intestines,
they're going to zip everything back up and all this is going to happen.
Supposedly without me being aware of it and I,
and I'm not having any part of it. I just said,
I was just lying there saying, I don't think this is working.
I'm not feeling anything. You're going to have to do something more.
I just want you to know that I'm not,
and then I was in another room and there was no one else there.
Where did they all go? Like they'd all left and then,
and then it occurred to me like, no. Oh, oh, oh,
the whole surgery is already happened. Wow. That is weird.
I just happened to me, if they spliced time,
take the time that you were in and the time that you are in subsequently,
and the middle is totally missing. No experience whatsoever.
It's not like sleep. No. There was no like, oh, I'm getting sleepy.
I was arguing with my doctors that they didn't know how to do their job and the
next thing I'm in a hospital room with my appendix out and it's 10 hours later.
It sort of implies that it's like a switch. Yeah, it is and that's what happens.
I mean when you raise the level of anesthesia in someone,
they've done studies on this, it isn't a gentle gradation down. You just,
you raise it up, you raise it up and then from you are into this other state.
Do do people who do this for a living know exactly why this happened.
You'd think that something that's been around since 1846 would be hammered out
solid, but it's still almost a philosophical kind of mystery.
[inaudible]
there's a term for this in physics it's called a black box refers to a system
where you can see what goes in,
you can see that something different comes out and you wonder like what happened
there in the middle, but you can't see it. Yeah, it's a mystery.
It's black and it's closed up. Therefore, the box,
I mean it might not literally be a box, but we have three different
attempts to open three very different black boxes. It's starting with the box.
It's in front of us now. That gap that Carl talked about, where you go, Oh,
you're gone, and then suddenly you're back.
What happens in that gap? That's what's crazy.
It's been almost 170 years since William Morton did his thing in front of those
med students. And we moved way beyond ether. So here we got Provo fall,
we've got CVL fluorine,
dex matters how many Caribbean we've got all these new drugs,
but we still don't know exactly how they work,
which for Patrick is a very practical problem.
It's very difficult actually to figure out when people, you know,
aren't conscious, cause they can always be internally conscious to some degree.
Right.
And in the 1950s and sixties he says this became a real issue because doctors
started giving patients neuromuscular blocking agents paralyze their muscles
during surgery so they wouldn't flop around, which is a good thing.
But then you'd have these situations,
oh,
once in a blue moon. Yeah.
[inaudible]
where a patient would wake up in the middle of surgery, literally trapped, um,
unable to move, eyes closed, totally still know, fully awake,
but no one would be able to perceive it because they couldn't move.
And that's the nightmare that, you know,
may even be worse than having six strong men hold you down. I, yeah.
We don't have to dwell on that. Well,
I actually did find a bunch of these stories. I don't want to hear them.
I know they're great. I mean, they're, they're, um, they're amazing. But, um,
all right. I'd like to hear about it. No, I'm just saying, Hey,
I'll just play you one. No, I didn't know. All right. All right. All right.
You aren't going to regret it. Well, anyway,
the larger point is that if you can understand how and why anesthesia works,
then you're not going to be able to explain why every so often it just doesn't
work. Okay. How often is every so often? Um,
I've heard different numbers anywhere between one and 10,000 to much more often,
like one in 1000. Wow. But luckily,
let's take a look at these brain signals. In the last few decades,
scientists have begun to shine a little pin light into this black box,
and Patrick and his team in particular have found something pretty cool.
This experiment that we did in the, I guess, late 2000 so a couple of years ago,
they wanted to know what happens in the brain,
right when that phone switch flips. So they got a bunch of volunteers,
all the volunteers, they hook them up to an ivy and started to very,
very slowly give them propofol. Slowly the admitters to the drug,
which is a big anesthetic, and as they did,
they told the subjects to click a button.
Every time they heard a sound or a word chair, a library that they recognize,
submarine, you know, something like that. In addition,
we had the subject's name too, Tim p, Patrick.
So the subjects would just sit there and listen and care library on and on.
Patrick and every 15 minutes that gave them a little bit more propofol. Yep.
Big 10 Michael
until eventually they just stopped responding altogether.
They were just out cold. Now throughout this whole time,
Patrick and his team were measuring the brain waves of the subjects.
That's the key.
And he says what they saw right at the moment that that switch flipped right at
the moment of loss of consciousness. There was just one really,
really clear motif that appeared.
They saw this wave of electricity sweeping across the brain
[inaudible]
this really low frequency oscillation about one cycle per second or less
[inaudible].
And in addition to that, there was this higher frequency piece,
an Alpha wave that appeared at the front of the head at that loss of
consciousness moment.
No.
So when people went under,
their brains just started to ring like a bell basically. And why would those,
what are those waves doing exactly?
It seems like those waves might be imposing a kind of deadly order on the brain.
This is the thing that's very counterintuitive.
You think that consciousness is order and synchrony,
but it turns out that it's kind of the opposite.
That consciousness is actually chaotic and noisy. It's all of those
different parts of the brain, you know, facial recognition,
touch sound language engaged in this crazily complicated,
multilayered conversation. You know, it's one person talking,
the other one talking back,
this is Carl Zimmer again and he says,
one of the hallmarks of the conscious brain is that you see a kind of
conversational logic of back and forth between the different parts. Yeah,
my turn, your turn, my turn, your turn,
the things you're seeing create signals in the back of your head.
They would go to the front of your head back again,
forward and back and forward and back and forward and back and forward and back.
And you can use this eavesdropping to calculate how connected the brain is,
what they call conductivity. And when you're awake,
you have a lot of connectivity. When you're dreaming,
you also have a lot of connectivity. Um,
and then if someone gives you anesthesia,
like in a matter of a second, your connectivity just collapses.
What happened to you? It just curved. Your connectivity got cut. It did.
And here is the weird part.
Scientists will like play a sound to somebody who's under with anesthesia and
they can see that actually the part of the brain that processes sound,
the auditory cortex is active. It takes in the sound.
So your brain is hearing sounds. Um, that's spooky. Yeah.
So what could be happening is that when you're under anesthesia,
all the different parts of your brain to, to some degree that could be awake.
It's not, not your brain is just stopping. No.
All those parts of the brain are still talking.
They're just not talking to each other very well anymore.
And that somehow knocks you out.
So lots of Chit chat amongst the different parts of my brain.
Make me conscious and not so much chitchat equals unconsciousness, you know,
that's the idea. And how do the slow waves, uh, relate to that?
Well, Patrick thinks of it in sort of in baseball terms,
right? So actually I was at a red sox game, um, uh,
the other day it was the last one that they had a, uh, with the,
with the Yankees, uh, at Fenway park this year. And, um,
at some point the wave started.
So some part of the stadium decided to to go into the wave and here,
here you go.
The waves coming around and coming around and you're watching it and it keeps
coming around and coming around and you know,
after a while it gets really tiresome because you're sitting there and just
like, okay, I've got a um, a wait for the wave to come. Okay, here's,
here it is like a kid stand up, raise our arms and sit back down. And,
and just a moment later and like, oh my God, I got to stand up again and,
and you're waiting. Oh dude, it's back again. And, and the thing is that when,
when the wave is going on in the stadium,
you can't really carry on a normal conversation.
You can't have a normal interaction.
You may not even be able to have a normal thought because the thing is just
coming by every couple seconds to interrupt you.
That is sort of the rationale for how these oscillations disrupt brain activity.
I dig the analogy, but I'm not quite following.
It helps to to zoom in on the brain and look at a smaller number of neurons.
Okay. Which is what he did. Now check this out.
We conducted this study where we measured brain activity and individual neurons.
They got some patients planted these tiny little electrodes deep into their
brains so they could hear the individual neurons.
So let's imagine that we zoom in to like tens to hundreds of neurons firing
and um, he says when they give that patient propafol and anesthetic,
what we notice is that right at the point of loss of consciousness, sure enough,
they see those big slow waves sweeping through. And just like in Fenway,
when the wave hits you, you have to stop your conversation.
But what that wave is really doing is it's only allowing each little cluster of
neurons to talk. Once in awhile.
They can only fire at a particular moment in this slow oscillation.
Like, you know, other wave goes up and down,
up and down or round and round and round. If you're on Penway,
it's only at this moment,
say that one group gets to talk problems. His buddy,
he can only talk at this moment and the neurons next door or they can only talk
in this moment. Next group, same deal.
Everybody gets a turn to talk,
but they can't talk to each other because on slightly different schedules when
they're talking, the others can't listen.
So there's still a lot of talking going on.
But consciousness seems to be the talking and listening to itself.
So when that slow wave rolls around the neurons cat all fire at the same time
and talk to one another and in that state it would be impossible to be
conscious. It might be early to say,
but it does it feel kind of like you cracked the code? Well,
I think we are in the process of cracking the code for a anesthesia.
You don't ever want to get too far in limb, but honestly,
I mean I feel if we can educate people about these rhythms, I I, you know,
I'd be willing to say it. Sure. I, I think we have,
I mean I think this is going to be huge. I'm not going to lie to you.
I think this is just going to be absolutely huge. Yeah. Oh,
I'll take the bait on that. Sure. Frack the coke. Really that's,
that's a little bold. Well, what it means to Patrick
[inaudible]
is that in very practical terms, he can now peak into that,
that black box of the brain. Okay. Here I am and wearing my scrubs. For example,
Patrick and his colleague Emery Brown.
I'm an anesthesiologist here at mass general.
They let me watch a couple of surgeries and I met a woman named Doris.
Good morning. What kind of a surgery are you having today
that you know, 107 years ago would have been unthinkable, but here she is
not too worried.
So they were about to give her the first anesthetic first anesthetic protocol.
That's right. Yet. And as she starts to go on there,
deep breath doors and stuff, some,
I'm going to just switch over the,
the spectrogram display and see what it shows.
Deep breath doors on one of these monitors. Oh, look at that.
Did you see the change? It's this color display. You can actually see it happen.
You can see the slow ways right now. Now she's got some slow oscillations.
If you imagine the screen is like this field of blues and yellows and Greens,
suddenly these bands of red just extend right along the bottom.
And considering that for the last hundred and 60 years,
anytime somebody like Doris has been put on a table and cut open,
the doctors basically couldn't be sure what was going on in their head.
Are they awake? Are they okay? And so with that in mind,
being there in the operating room and seeing that band of red appear on the
screen and hearing Emery brown declare without hesitation,
this patient is unconscious. It's kind of cool.
And you say that with a a w what percent confidence?
99.9
(999) 999-9999
[inaudible].
And then I was in another room.
Where did they all go?